what's up everyone it's Warren and we
did it we hit 500,000 subscribers
honestly this is a day that I really
didn't expect to happen when I started
YouTube I didn't ever think enough
people would want to watch my videos for
me to have this many subscribers but
I've gotten a lot of support from all of
you and I really really appreciate it I
appreciate all of the comments even
though I don't always reply to all of
them I do read them a lot of you have
been subscribed to me for a really long
time and I just want to say thank you so
much for sticking with me for this long
and for everybody that is newly
subscribed to my channel I want to say
thank you as well and I hope you enjoy
the rest of my videos that I'm going to
put out for as long as I possibly can I
know it may not mean much to you guys
that you support me but seriously it
means everything to me because I never
thought that I could be a youtuber I
just thought that I was going to talk
about something that I loved and maybe
something would come of it but I never
thought I would ever have half a million
subscribers and thanks to y'all I get to
talk about something that I love every
single day and people actually care
which is kind of amazing in fact you've
all made it possible to where I could
start my own personal YouTube channel
culture captains it's my comedy channel
that I started with my friend and editor
of this channel Chris and you've also
made it to where I can join my other new
channel multiverse and on multiverse I
get to talk about all types of
superheroes and not even just
superheroes everything that is
pop-culture and I have a great team with
multiverse and you all have made it
possible for me so seriously thank you
all from the bottom of my heart but I
know why you're here let's get into the
giveaway but just so you all know right
now multiverse is doing a Nintendo
switch giveaway so click the link in the
description down below for your chance
to enter that and my channel culture
captains is going to be doing a big
giveaway as well really soon so be sure
to go over and subscribe to both
channels so the rules for this giveaway
were to be subscribe to my channel and
comment on my videos with your favorite
superhero or villain the winner is
chosen completely at random by a youtube
program that I have and the winner is
Josiah bogman congratulation Josiah you
just won my 500,000 subscriber giveaway
now do - every time I do a contest a
bunch of people email me claiming to be
the winner I have already contacted
Josiah to
get him his prize he will get to choose
between an Xbox one or ps4 it is his
choice and for those of you who did not
win don't worry you know it of course
I'm going to be doing another giveaway
when we hit five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers I'll be giving away
at consoles again an Xbox one or a ps4
the users choice so be sure to subscribe
to my channel watch my videos and
comment who your favorite superhero or
villain is again I just really want to
thank everybody for sticking with me for
so long and supporting my channel it
means everything to me so as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof